I'd like to talk to you about the house
[Music]
what is it in that house Claire isn't
doing why is it trying to reach me
all right time for another movie review
I'm actually really excited about this
one yeah this is uh another forgotten
classic yes The Changeling yeah this is
1980 and this is a really good movie
actually it's it's forgotten
basically yeah it is it seems to be very
underrated like it does turn up on you
know kind of experts hundred best horror
movies and stuff most of the list I've
seen a hundred best horror movies have
this on it but I do feel like a lot of
people haven't seen it now I saw it too
I probably saw it on cable came out in
1980 so it was probably on cable in
maybe 82 or 83 which i think is when i
saw it and i remember being really
really creepy because and i'm sure i've
mentioned this on other movie reviews
70's and 80's haunted house movies
actually just any creepy old school
haunted house movies that is like my
favorite horror sub-genre yeah if it's
done right if it's done right on it yeah
like I especially like ones that are
very subtle that are very atmospheric
you know I mean one of my favorite
horror films of all time is the haunting
from 1963 which like I said before it's
it's scary because it doesn't show
anything it's all suggestion and this is
another one along those same lines yeah
probably why I love it so it does show
things but it just shows you just enough
for people who like paranormal this
would be a really good movie for because
in the ass parapsychology seances EVPs
there were some EVPs apparitions and
even though I personally you know I was
involved in a poltergeist episode I've
never really seen a haunted house right
I've been in a bad house but I've never
been in what people would call a haunted
house but if there were hot houses which
there may be most likely they're like
this which is there is some poltergeist
phenomenon and then there's some
messages from the dead that type of
stuff pretty cool but I think the
coolest thing about
this movie and the coolest thing about
haunted house movies in general that
don't you know go flying off the rails
and show an all kind of stupid [ __ ] is
that these seem a lot more grounded and
believable which to me makes them
scarier because you know when you're
showing like ghosts flying around
everywhere and you know eating people
and [ __ ] it's like obviously that's not
gonna happen and that run but you know
when you're showing ones where like you
know door opens by itself or a piano key
plays by itself or do you know it's all
done by suggestion like that I'm like
that could totally happen and you would
wet yourself there's a really good scene
with a ball yeah and you know I don't
really want to spoil it but just red
ball with a stripe on it people who've
seen the movie know what I'm talking
about that scene with the ball reminds
me a lot of Mammoth Mountain poltergeist
yeah it's that type of thing right
that's what that that's what a culture
guys is like yeah except faster really
cool and I feel like I mean because this
movie is even though it's old it's fit
was made in 1980 I kind of I don't
really want to spoil it or you know say
what the solution of the mystery is or
anything like that just in case because
maybe some of you have seen it but maybe
not yeah and I actually do recommend
that you watch it and I think that kind
of because it's sort of like a ghost
story but it's also a murder mystery
yeah so I feel like unraveling the
mystery for you kind of takes away a lot
of its power and a lot of you know I
want people to like appreciate it the
movie was very influential on other
directors and other oh yes all right one
of the good things about it is the
casting the casting is spot-on and the
acting is spot on the it's starring
George C Scott yeah all right so and
he's playing a music teacher music
professor but he's basically being
Patton imagine Patton being haunted by a
ghost well the best thing about his
performance is I think exactly I mean
because he played Patton because he was
in dr. Strangelove and stuff like I
think you kind of expect him to be like
this big angry type of thing and I think
it's cool that he doesn't really do that
but on the other hand he doesn't get
wigged out like by the haunting like
he's kind of like disturbed by it but he
is very proactive he's like okay well
obviously this is a ghost obviously
they're trying to tell me something I
need
you're out arrives at the bottom of it
yeah he takes up the mission I'm trying
to figure out what this ghost wants but
what was really cool is when he finally
sees the Epirus we're not finally he
sees the apparition pre or early on it
scares him so much that he nearly faints
but he overcomes his fear after that
he's not a cowardly guy he's like I said
he's like a brave Patton
type [ __ ] trying to solve this
problem or solve this quest that a ghost
is put him on you'll see yeah really
good movie yeah I mean and the whole um
the whole premise of the movie is as I
said George sees God he plays a music
professor composer yeah now at the very
beginning of the movie his wife and
daughter are killed like in a freak road
accident when they're on vacation in
upstate New York all in the snow and
stuff like that and because he was he
could just kind of watch it he couldn't
do anything to help them
so I think he kind of felt like this
weird helplessness because he just
watched it happen it was this horrible
accident and so a few months after that
he decides he's going to move out to
Seattle it's supposedly sent in Seattle
the movie was actually filmed mostly in
Vancouver and at the University of
Toronto it's essentially a Canadian
movie and before you forget this movie
is actually based on a real case yeah I
want to talk about that we're talking
like that in this so you know this kind
of predates what you see with a haunting
series yeah and there's a lot about this
movie when you look at the first seizing
of a hot season of a haunting yeah I can
see how they were trying to get some of
their episodes to be kind of like this
movie some of the very like in the first
season the good ones oh yeah but they
were trying to achieve this tone I think
yeah and you know some of them succeeded
some Hamas's but honestly I see summer
wind yes yes everyone this is seriously
and like I said I love haunted house
movies I love the haunting I love burnt
offerings at levels this is actually one
of the best ones you know some reviewers
I've seen have place it up there with
the shining yeah I'm not I don't think
it's better than the shining but it's
definitely up there sit League it's in
league with the shining I think it's
kind of a different sort of film shining
some masterpieces yes but so okay so he
moves out to Seattle now he is contacted
through mutual friends because he gets a
job at a university teaching music and
he's trying to compose and
so evidently he wants some place where
he wears quiet and large and he can work
in peace and stuff so this woman from
the Historical Society contacts and
she's like oh we have this big mansion
it's got a big music room the historical
said he owns it we're renting it out for
assume assume fairly cheap and so he
goes and moves into it now interestingly
trish van Devere who plays Claire the
woman at the Historical Society is
actually George C Scott's real-life wife
they married in 1972 and they were
married until he died in 1999 so there's
kind of like it's not really a love
interest relationship it's a little bit
like that yeah but they're more kind of
like they strike up a friendship and she
helps him investigate because she works
for the Historical Society she's only
worked there for about a year so she
doesn't know a huge amount about the
house but he gets curious about it when
he has all these you know at first
subtle paranormal manifestations
happening ya know what
one thing about this house is this house
is gorgeous yes huge and we watched it
we were like where is this I was like I
want that man and then after the movie
was over we started doing research on
this show and turns out that that was a
set yeah and that the front of that
house was just a facade yeah the outside
of it is a facade built over a modern
now he would never know the inside was
an interconnecting series yes sense and
you would never ever you would never
ever know that that wasn't a real house
no I was I was absolutely floored when
they decide that and here's another
weird thing about this movie as great as
this movie is it only cost $600,000 I
couldn't believe that either that blew
my mind the scores badass the sets are
badass the writing the stories really
cool by today's standards
I think teenagers would say this movie
is kind of slow it's a slow burner right
they would say that the shining is slow
- all right so the shining is slow but
the thing about that movie and the thing
about this movie is that you're so
invested in the character and you're so
intrigued by what's going to happen that
George G Scott brings it in this
yeah he really makes it happen they
slowly ratchet up the tension on you in
this movie he's really forget that
that's right I mean I think he lends the
movie a lot of gravitas that's one of
the things I like about this movie is
that and you saw this in a lot of 70s
haunted house movies pair of
psychological type movies it's taken
very seriously it's not treated as a
joke it's not treated like as a lark or
anything like that like no one really
makes fun of him or anything and he
takes it very seriously I mean obviously
he's skeptical at first yeah because at
first he's just hearing these banging
sounds is like oh maybe it's the
plumbing maybe it's this that and the
other thing but as time goes on he just
he seems to just accept okay this is a
spirit it's trying to tell me something
what are we going to do about it so he's
very matter-of-fact yeah and you know
it's an ode else is funny though now you
bring up lecture parapsychology angle
and you know how this movie unfolds you
can really see how this movie influenced
the movie poltergeist yeah that
poltergeist in a way was kind of like a
knockoff of this movie but instead of it
being a slow-burning mystery ghost story
poltergeist was an action flick action
adventure yeah a flick so but you could
see that I could see I could see a lot
of poltergeist in this do you know also
a little more recently something that a
movie that was really influenced by this
was insidious I didn't see that movie oh
it's it's actually not bad but but you
can really tell it like that it was
influenced by this movie and there's
kind of it's funny because maybe
watching it now because it's kind of
been I don't know I don't want to say
ripped off but I know omage so many
times right now people will be like oh
well this the other thing but it's like
this is kind of the one that did a lot
of those things first yeah some of the
best scenes about it I gotta say like I
said the interior of the house yeah
beautiful I wish it was a real house cuz
I want it I don't care if it's on it or
not and no spoilers remember
no I'm not gonna spoil anything I was
gonna say actually one of the best
things about this is the what and what
really makes it creepy is the
cinematography the camerawork and stuff
like that it's really cool because the
director who was Peter medic and I want
to talk about him a little bit too
because he had kind of a weird video
syncretic sort of career he shoots the
film almost as though it's kind of like
from the POV of the spirits maybe but
not in a real overt way raah like he
does like all these long tracking shots
like down these creepy halls and all
that kind of stuff and it's just it's
really effective like there's a lot of
scenes like looking down on George's you
stop from like way up on the third floor
staircase and things like that and it's
really it really like brings a really
creepy atmosphere to the one it's very
claustrophobic the sort of
claustrophobic house and all the stuff
that's going on in it and I think
another one of the best scenes that I'm
particularly thinking of that a city
insidious kind of paid homage to was the
seance scene now the weirdest thing and
I think I mentioned this on another
review that we did for some reason
something that creeps me out a lot is
people's voices like you people's voices
have like a really flat effect or or if
they're talking normal and then their
voice suddenly changes you know like in
The Shining where the kids like you know
that freaks me out
so the creepiest thing about this seance
scene is that psychics voice how did you
die it's bit yeah it's very flat and
it's very just like it's why are you not
at rest later on Georgie Scott goes to
the tape he finds EVPs on there the
movie I saw that you couldn't hear that
when you know you couldn't hear it when
they were doing this and another thing
that's good later another thing that's
going on you know there are a few
reviews of this movie on YouTube one of
them stunt by a young guy don't remember
what his name was but I just I'm
tripping out that a lot that this movie
is starting to pick up a lot of younger
fans yeah
and I think it's because kind of the
Renaissance that's going on in the end
or film yeah we're but there's a lot of
throwback thing to the 70s well a lot of
the eighties stuff was afloat was a
throwback to the 70s movies and a lot of
the seventies movies were being
influenced by this so for a lot of the
eighties movies well as funny as that
average movie goers an average average
fans don't know about this movie but
this movie is available right now on
YouTube that's usually up there for free
yeah and that's just I'm just giving you
a tip yeah it's probably up if you
search for it yeah we we were able to
find it we actually bought the DVD yeah
it's available on Amazon for very cheap
at five or six dollars yeah there was no
blu-ray blu-ray except in Japan but I've
heard that the transfer is shitty yeah
and there's a guy in Brazil who is
trying to sell a blu-ray international
release I'm skeptical why is there only
one in Brazil yeah it yeah that's what
everything you might not be am I think
it might be a fake I think it's a DVD
with a fake cover on it if you ask me I
don't know yeah it may be but wait I
lost a lot of money when we yeah and
when we looked for the blu-ray now was
that the one that cost like 139 dollars
you know the Japanese really be up to
160 dollars yeah and like I said I
haven't seen it but I've heard that the
transfer is poor so I bought the DVD for
six dollars used yeah yeah um it would
be nice if it got a blu-ray release
could it really is a good-looking movie
it's a well acted movie it's a man
written movie it's just big for buck out
of this movie is 13 out 10 this is six
dollars to make this movie I could not
believe that that's amazing it's amazing
I mean especially considering I mean at
first it didn't sound that crazy because
I thought they were filming in a real
house but then when I found out no those
are all sets that they don't on sound
stages yeah I was like holy Sh you never
know threadable
yeah I never would have guessed that in
a million years oom dit was a real house
and then at the end I'm not gonna spoil
the amber at the end I'm a litecoin god
damn did they really do that yeah
I wanted to talk a little bit about
Peter medic the guy that directed this
the weird thing is that he was really
only the third choice the first choice
direct this movie weirdly enough and I
swear we did not do this on purpose was
what's his name Peter Kamel the guy that
directed demon seed who reviewed last
week yes so he was the first the first
choice and then he had creative
differences and then there's another guy
and he had also had creative differences
and then they got Peter medic to do it
Peter medic has done some really weird
movies he didn't really do much more
horror I think he directed species too
he did or the gay blade he did like it
just a bunch of weird movies and he
actually I was like I knew his name I
was I got his name is so familiar what
have I seen that he's done because I
haven't seen you tour the gay blade and
I didn't see species two either and then
I remembered if you guys remember the
the series I think it was on Showtime
Masters of Horror there's two seasons
and you know they had an hour long thing
that was directed by different you know
Masters of Horror obviously and he did
the one the episode that was called the
Washingtonians yeah he didn't write it
it was actually based on a short story
about how George Washington was a super
cannibal and stuff like that yeah as a
cult of George Washington cannibals yeah
and it was and it's funny because this
movie is just so low-key and Atmospheric
and creepy and everything like that and
then for him to direct the
Washingtonians which was like the zany
astoria like over-the-top episode of
that show I just thought was very
strange but so you know I don't know I
feel like he kind of deserved better so
where do you place this movie do you
place it how do you place it in terms of
say the legacy how's it going I actually
like this better than the legacy okay
what about Exorcist well The Exorcist is
okay so it's not quite as good as yes
system right okay there's a really hard
for me too and it's funny because after
we watched it last night and then we
were watching a couple reviews of it
like just just to see what younger
people thought of it when it or whatever
and then one of the guys who've done a
review of it he also him and his friend
had done this three and a half hour
podcast yeah about they had taken the
time out one
the list of 100 best horror movies which
are actually voted on by different
writers and directors and everything
like that in the genre and they just
kind of went through and like broke down
each of the films whether they thought
it should be on the lid whether it be on
their list or whatever and I actually
sat there and watched the whole thing
or listened to the whole thing they
didn't annoy me until later because it
seemed like a lot of the movies they
hadn't seen which to me seems kind of
dumb I've seen a probably about 95% of
the ones that were on that list and they
had seen maybe 60% of them and there
were some that were kind of like that
they really didn't like that I didn't
get why hmm you know and stuff like that
The Changeling was on that list I
believe it was number 29 or 30 I seem to
remember it was right in front of
Videodrome okay so whoever made this
list or you know it was voted on like I
said don't you put it on par with I
would put it now see and what I was
getting up to was that watching that I
was like man one of these days I'm gonna
do one of these podcasts and I'm gonna
pick my 100 I don't want to say 100 best
horror movies I would I would say my 100
favorite horror movies because I do like
some horror movies that I know are
probably not objectively good but but
that I but I enjoyed for whatever reason
I would put this movie like I said it
ended up 29 or 30 on that top 100 best I
would probably put it a bit higher than
that just because haunted house movies
from that era like my favorite I would
it would easily be in my top 20 what
movie would it be on par with it that's
what I'm asking on par with ooh it's
almost as good as the haunting from 1960
throat which is one of my favorite which
is my favorite haunted house movie ever
I would say okay so my favorite haunted
house movies the haunting The Shining
right and then this one okay so it's my
third favorite modern okay so that's
what I'm gonna say I think it's an
awesome movie it is it's really really
good and like I said you you kinda have
to be in the mood for it it's you know
it's very it's a slow-burning kind of
movie it's very low-key you know it's
better if you watch like an a stormy
night or something and it's all joke and
you just kind of you know get immersed
in it now as you said this movie is act
it's not based on a book but it's
actually the one the guy that one of the
guys that worked on the screenplay it
was based on his actual experiences now
he was living in Denver Colorado in the
late 60s and everything you see in this
movie where he moves to a house he
starts hearing banging on the walls
doors opening and closing things like
that and then he finds out that you know
the the house is haunted by this boy
that was murdered and that you know
everything I'm not gonna spoil but
everything that happens in the movie
like finding the Attic sits closer
behind the closet and everything like
that
he claims pretty much what happened in
the movie he had the seance everything
is exactly what happened to him all
right now it should be noted that you
know I don't know how much corroborating
evidence there is for this about the
haunting about the seance about the
murder or anything like that but if you
watch this movie that is pretty much
exactly what he claims happened to him
in real life all right
well also the other another famous booth
is based on a real case kind of from
this era would have been Amityville
Horror
and I always remember really like in
Amityville but having watched it again
several times recently over the past
couple years when you look at a medieval
today it looks like a made-for-tv movie
at that CNN don't really find it scary
this one is better than an evil oh yeah
well like I said this one has it has
more of a of a gravity to it it has no
class yeah ambi the horror scared me a
lot when I was a kid yeah and I still
like it it's just that it's nostalgia
the reason why we liked it I think yeah
I mean I still like it as a movie but
it's not as scary as I remembered yeah
the writing isn't as good yeah it's a
little ramshackle the way it was shot it
looks pretty bad it looks made-for-tv
well it's not very it doesn't have like
a distinct aesthetic glare or anything
like that
I think is something that this movie
does in spades it's a beautiful movie
like this shots are very this movie just
goes to show you to make a good movie
you don't need money you just need a lot
of talent guys don't know how to write
they write their stories good actors and
then know how to shoot a movie yeah and
the movie the movie looks like a classic
I mean it's classic oh yeah that's like
a masterpiece and like I said it it
seems to be one that even though it
seems appreciated in horror aficionado
circles it's kind of one that a lot of
people don't seem to have seen yeah you
know the YouTube transfer isn't that
great yes yeah it's okay but the DVDs
gonna be a lot better yeah we just
ordered it after where I watched it last
night because I don't now you had seen
this my scene for you I thought you
would seen it but when we were talking
about doing this for the show because I
was originally I was gonna do ghost
story and we are actually gonna do that
one that's I got two requests for that
so far I've been wanting to do ghost
story it was already list because I
really like that movie Anna and the book
is really a bunch of movies here the
other day so you know the brood is in
there so you guys get yourself ready
yeah this this movie I kind of feel like
this movie and ghost story are kind of
similar Melvyn Douglas was in he played
the senator in the changeling it was
also in ghost story a year later then
that was actually this last movie and
it's a similar kind of vibe I actually
think this one I haven't seen ghost
story in several years and I actually
really like no story but I think this
one I would give the edge I think I like
this one a bit better the interesting
thing about this and I did not know this
I just discovered it while I was
researching this movie is that in 87
there was an Italian made-for-tv movie
that was directed by the infamous
Lombardo Bava and it was supposedly
supposed to be like it's sometimes
called The Changeling
to like I suppose equal to this alright
even though it really doesn't have
anything it's called yeah it's called
until death and the funny thing about it
was that it was written by Dardano soo
Shetty who if you know anything about
Italian horror was actually he worked
with the geophone she a lot and who
actually wrote a lot of Lucio Phil
cheese best movies the Beyond House by
the cemetery and all of those and
evidently this movie until death is the
one that caused the rift
between Lucci Oh bull Chi and Dardano
soo Shetty because each of them took
credit for writing it but like I said it
doesn't really have anything to do with
the first changeling it's more like a
supernatural or straight horror take off
of the postman Rings Twice so I'm not
really sure why they picked the
changeling of all things I don't maybe
that was a huge hit in Italy I don't
know but yes so there if there isn't in
name only sequel to it which I thought
was really interesting because like I
said I'm really into a telling horror
and I didn't know that but yeah this is
definitely definitely one to check out
if you haven't seen it [ __ ] Martin
Scorsese called it one of his you know
top 10 or top 11 scariest movies ever
the thing is you have to approach it
from the perspective of the time ya know
jump scares no no it doesn't really have
any jump scares it doesn't have any CGI
obviously songs made in 1980 there's
there's really nothing overt everything
is suggestion everything is the way it's
shot like I said very much like the
haunting which doesn't really show
anything but these does happen but yeah
it's just everything is the way it's
filmed like with weird angles and like
suggestion and noises and things like
that so if you watch it like in a dark
room and use like by yourself and stuff
you know yeah it would it will give you
the willies having actually witnessed
poltergeist phenomena myself personally
this movie actually looks more realistic
for me yeah well that's why that's why I
think it's creepy yeah because nothing
that's all that crazy happens right like
everything all possible it's pretty
plausible right and it's treated as
plausible by the people in the movie and
apparitions people having visions voices
sounds yeah a portation asportation of
objects yes but it's my various minors
yes restraints not a poltergeist one
where you have 20-foot tall faces coming
out of parallel dimensions and things
grabbing yeah well I mean I like
poltergeist I like that movie it's an
action but it's just fun yeah yeah it's
like a fun action movie that happens to
be about ghosts it's not the way a rope
guys tonight outbreak looks this is a
lot more along the lines of just like a
creepy old-fashioned haunted house Peck
type of movie which I said that's like
my favorite sub-genre
it's got the Jenny stamp of approval on
yes so definitely check it out if you
haven't already remember if you like the
show to like share subscribe on all your
social media and if you'd like to
support the show check out our patreon
or our blog at 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and go to the link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account if you'd
like to make a one-time donation also
remember to tune in for our next regular
episode which is coming up on Tuesday
and our movie reviews come out every
Friday and that'll do it for this
episode go see The Changeling not to be
confused with the Angelina Jolie Clint
Eastwood directed movie about this kid
switch that we actually did a show on
that the wine bill chicken commuters but
it's not that that was it that was a
decent movie too but this is totally not
this is totally different with George C
Scott's changed yeah so go check it out
and we will see you next time bye